how may we know we have not committed
the unpardonable sin first of all the
Bible says in Philippians 2 13
Philippians 2 13 it is God that worketh
in you both the will and to do of his
good pleasure
to will means to want to do right let me
ask you do you want to do right
then you have not committed the
unpardonable sin the Apostle Paul
speaking of this dread condition in the
book of Ephesians chapter 4 and verse 19
mention some who are past feeling
they have gone so far into sin they have
hardened their hearts so much that
nothing can reach them Paul says they
are past feeling don't play with this
however but tonight if it's in your
heart to do right to obey God you have
not committed the unpardonable sin
Pastor doesn't the bible say that God
created everything perfect and then Adam
and Eve sinned but God also cast The
Devil down unto the Earth with a third
of the angels in heaven why then do some
people say that the Angels aren't
perfect are they or are they not well
the ones that are they are the ones that
weren't were put out that's the answer
to your question in fact your answer is
contained in the question when Satan and
his hosts were cast out Rebellion ceased
in heaven and now it's confined to the
Earth Revelation chapter 12 says woe to
the inhabitants of the earth and of the
sea for the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knoweth
hands but a short time Pastor is it
almost time for Jesus to come because he
said the days would get shorter and it
seems to me I'm getting out of school
earlier
[Applause]
no that's not quite what it means you
still have 24 hours in a day
but when the Lord spoke of the time
being short and he meant time as a whole
being shortened not the days being
shortened in hours it didn't mean that
but the end is near we don't set dates
the Bible forbids that but the Bible
tells us we may know when his coming is
near and the violence in Oklahoma city
is another sign next please Dr Brooks
what would you say about Acts 19 11 and
12 miracles and handkerchiefs aprons
disease departed and evil spirits went
out also the laying on of hands of the
sick are we to believe in this kind of
power what you really I suppose ought to
be asking do we believe in Divine
Healing the answer is yes I am the
subject of Divine Healing God has healed
me in an instant just like that and it
happens all around us all the time but
whenever God does anything good Satan
creates caliphates and the Bible says in
the last days Miracle working would be
one of the means of deception by the
devil would you say Amen now we've read
that to you more than once and I'm going
to read it to you tonight and so we
because of God's genuine we have to be
wary of the canopies and when people
heal for money and become rich doing it
and for profit and heal indiscriminately
anybody that comes along that that does
not comply with Biblical teaching
concerning healing God did not even heal
Saint Paul
in fact he told Paul to stop asking
and Paul understood it once God spoke to
him like that he said lest I be exalted
above measure God gave me this Thorn In
the Flesh and then he said I rather
therefore glory in my infirmity that the
Excellency might be of God and not of me
that's not God's way you come down the
aisle anybody some people are
responsible for the old problems and
these healers don't even tell him to
stop drinking liquor
that's not God's way
but he still heals next please why did
God regret that he had made Saul King
doesn't he know everything about
everything so didn't he know beforehand
I I wish it with all my heart and I'm
saying this kindly I wish we would
listen a little more carefully because
we cover all of this when we talk
when we talked about Saul we mentioned
the fact that God's foreknowledge does
not mean predestination the way it is
taught or fatalism the way it is taught
God does not force the human mind
God will lead God implores God pleads
God Woos God guides but he does not
force and so God gave Saul an
opportunity to do right he chose to do
wrong and this caused the implied regret
next please
in First Corinthians meets for the belly
and belly for Meats but God shall
destroy both it and them didn't Jesus
eat meat is this contrary to what Jesus
ate and what does meat in the scripture
mean and the scripture meat sometimes
means simply Bill Affair Jesus said one
day my need is to do the will of him
that sent me it's not a question of
whether it's right or wrong we've got a
subject coming up on that this week uh
title this week is death fried and
boiled stewed and broiled that's
Wednesday night next please Esther I
like to have a half glass of beer to
help me fall asleep every once in a
while on a rare occasion when I have
insomnia is this okay with God no it's
not okay with God
that let's not laugh this is an honest
question beloved and there are people
who even in the pulpits it's all right
to drink wine and liquor and everything
else but when a person is converted to
God God becomes that person's rest Jesus
said come unto me all you that live in
the heavy laden and I will give you rest
and as peace with God is established in
the heart we are able to go to sleep in
him and if you have to lie awake then
pray prayer not be a beer is forbidden
next please what does God say about
gambling people play Bingo and win money
or prizes from Bingo is that wrong the
Bible says by their fruit shall you know
them the gambling industry was illegal
in this country for many many years now
for money for money for money States and
governments are prostituting themselves
and creating lotteries and creating the
fruit of such evil it is not God's will
ladies and gentlemen a Christian does
not live by chance but by the blessings
of God and when I am blessed by God I do
not thank my lucky stars I thank the
good Lord you are better off to get away
from this and there's lot there are many
other statistical proofs that it is not
a good thing to do next please how can
we help a friend be firmly anchored in
the church rather than being blown about
by every wind of Doctrine the best thing
to do is two things three things teach
set an example and pray we cannot win
souls we cannot save souls and if
anybody in the church wants to be blown
by every when that person is free to do
so but what we can do is give the good
word secondly set the good example and
thirdly pray pray fast and pray and many
overcome like that next please today in
Sabbath School it was mentioned that
Rahab and her family were saved why then
when Aiken stole a wedge of gold and a
Babylonian garment was his whole family
destroyed please don't question the
Judgment of God
for your benefit don't ever fall into
that trap of questioning the Judgment of
God
told Rahab through Joshua that if she
would hang the red cord in the window
she could be saved I would like to
venture and answer to your question
Rahab was a holot and a heathen who had
more faith than a man who had been
taught diligently in the things of God
it is more serious to sin against light
than to sin when you have not known
better this woman did not know and even
before she had full light she believed
and was saved by faith the other man
tried to get away with it and God
appealed to him when they started
casting lots he could have repented but
he didn't until the finger was on him
and then it was too late we can go until
it's too late next please Pastor is
there more than one devil I'm trying to
answer quickly but I'm not being Curt
with you I think you understand that
don't you now is there more than one
devil we generally refer to Satan as the
devil and he is but there were many
Devils cast out of Heaven these fallen
angels are down here with him a conclave
of demons devils and they all around
here I ask the Lord every night to keep
him out of this church next please
Pastor should we pray for something more
than once and when we pray and the
answer is wait how long I don't know how
long that's up to God but let me tell
you something Jesus told a parable about
a woman she's called the unfortunate
that word unfortunate means the one who
keeps on doing it and doesn't stop and
is persistent this woman asks something
of the unjust judge and he ignored her
and she kept asking and kept asking and
kept asking and finally he said I fear
neither God nor man but because she
keeps on asking I'm going to answer and
the Lord implied or teaches us through
that message that we ought not give up
on God too soon we are not informing God
when we pray
prayer doesn't bring God down to us it
lifts us up toward God
we are not telling God what we need he
already knows and he is The Giver of
every good and perfect gift but prayer
Works something out in us so we must
persist in prayer and not let go of the
arm of the Lord too soon next please our
final question you remember Elijah on
Mount Carmel he kept praying and he
would send his servant to see if rain
was going to come and he went and came
back don't see a thing when he came back
don't see anything but he kept on
praying and finally he said I see a
little Cloud rising out of the sea and I
want to tell you the rain came God
answers persistent prayer I'm sorry
Pastor all right I am 15 years old is it
right for my mother to sit in the Next
Room when a boy comes to see me and we
want a little privacy
you're 15 years old is it right for your
mother to sit next room no that's not
right
your mother ought to sit in the room
with you
the bigger the hurry the quicker you'll
get there
why don't you enjoy childhood and there
are some things that are natural to
childhood but be careful and a good
mother will help you to be careful and
when the time comes you can fly
pastor we start with a young person
tonight when you feel like you're really
frustrated and like you're going to hurt
someone what should you do oh don't hurt
anybody
the thing that you should do is learn to
pray we're told by the pen of
inspiration that the highest evidence of
Christianity in a person is self-control
we've come to a time when everybody just
flies to pieces and figures he can do
anything he wants to do
but people who are civilized and
especially who are Christians are
supposed to exercise some kind of
control and the time to learn to do that
is when you're young
always turn away
and always pray
when things are getting out of hand ask
the Lord to help you you can't pray in
sin at the same time
here's someone who wants to know if God
knew that Satan would hate God why did
God make him in the first place God
didn't make Satan
God made an Angel by the name of lucify
everything that left the hand of God was
perfect
Lucifer made himself see
and in the same sense you if you become
a sinner you decide that God wants to
save you and make a saint out of you but
if you're determined to be a sinner you
may make that choice God gave to the
angels and to man The Power of Choice he
will not have us serve him as puppets we
are free moral agents we may decide and
choose and Lucifer chose the evil way
next please Pastor when Jesus comes you
said it would be the end of time do you
mean for Earth do you mean for all
eternity doesn't God and Jesus live
forever or won't they live forever and
if there's an ending to time and God I
don't understand let me try to help you
first of all let's try to make a
distinction between Time and Eternity
when God is eternal never bounded by
time
human beings are bounded by time as a
matter of fact the Bible says generally
the days of our years are three school
years and ten and if by reason of
strength they'd be four square Years yet
is their strength labor and sorrow for
it is soon cut off we come into the
world on time and we are going out after
a while but God is not affected by time
and when Jesus comes
eternity and time will have a collision
and those of us who are saved will enter
into
eternity with God God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have what Everlasting we
become
Eternal if we say time will have no
meaning after that next please Pastor
why do people always hassle me about my
friends after all nobody can make me do
wrong
well that's true but let me tell you
something they might not make you do
wrong but they can surely influence you
one of the worst habits you can form is
going around with bad folks now
sometimes to make my point I have to
speak very clearly
don't ever keep company with sorry
people
except to try to help them please
understand that we're not talking about
an attitude of superiority or anything
like that we're simply talking about
people who are determined not to do
right you hang with them and they will
influence you now they might not be able
to make you
but they will certainly create an
atmosphere that will make it easy for
you to conform to them rather than them
conform to you and The Company You Keep
is an index to your character birds of a
feather do what flock together but the
question really is not so much that you
know what the question is why do you
want to associate with people like that
that's the question
there is some breach there is some
problem if you are comfortable with
immoral people
the problem is bigger than most people
are willing to admit do you understand
what I'm saying why would you want to do
that sometimes young ladies say they
fall in love with some of these real
Rascals I've Seen It All My Life
and they say I'm in love how can you be
in love with someone who has nothing to
offer who is morally bankrupt
unless you are the same way
the Bible says now beseech your brethren
mark them which cause divisions and
offenses contrary to the doctrine which
ye have learned and avoid them
that's Romans 16 17. let me read one
more in the book of second Thessalonians
chapter 3 I want you to hear this second
Thessalonians chapter 3 I'm almost there
and I'm going to read verse 14. this is
what the Bible says and if any man will
be not our word by this epistle note
that man and have no company with him
that he may be ashamed good advice stay
out of Bad Company I know a man that
went to jail and stayed 22 years
and he really didn't commit the crime he
was just with the wrong crowd next
please
man because he was my best buddy in high
school
and he went into prison
in
1948 and he got out
when I was preaching for years and ran
into him in Cincinnati Ohio next week
I'm sorry it's all right one of our
friends here wants to know what is the
shortest book in the Bible
I uh we always get questions like this
another day we got one how many letters
or how many words are in the Bible and
and honestly when people ask these
questions they usually know the answer
already
and they want to see if you know
well let me give you two in the Old
Testament it's Obadiah in the New
Testament it's second John next please
my friend thinks that God Church pastors
the Son of God the holy spirit all of
this seems a bit stupid Please prove
that all of this stuff is not stupid I
guess this is what from one of our young
friends again oh my young friend I don't
have to prove that
there is evidence for those who are
reasonable and sensible that there is a
God there is a power called the Holy
Ghost the man came once from some faith
I don't want to mention and he wanted to
debate with me and when he got there I
said what are we going to use as final
Authority
I knew I didn't believe what he had
brought and he didn't believe the Bible
so I said we might as well talk about
the weather
why we start dying
I said but before we dismiss the man I
want you to explain something to me I
used to cuss I used to have an awful
temper I used to smoke I used to drink
what made the difference if there is no
God why am I like I am
by the way the Bible says the fool have
said in his heart there is no God
someone wants to know are dinosaurs
man-made are they a man-made reality or
are they for real were they written were
they here before the Bible was written
or during the time of the Bible where
does the Bible speak about dinosaurs
Evolution confuses the mind when they
find dinosaur bones they talk about
millions and millions of years ago the
amazing thing is they were supposed to
have been here millions of years before
man evolved and yet down in a riverbed
in Texas they found human Footprints and
dinosaur dinosaur footprints side by
side science really that speaks contrary
to the Bible is not science at all all
of this stuff called evolution is based
on and hypotheses it is not based on
fact it's a theory now God in the
beginning created the Heaven the Earth
until then there was nothing here all
life came from God and we believe that
these creatures these monsters that are
found in the rocks in Nevada and Montana
and other places we believe that these
creatures were here at least the The
Germ of light was here and some of them
are mutations Satan experimenting I
remember answering this question before
I told you that my nephew has a doberman
Venture he is bad his name is danger
now they didn't always have Doberman
pictures a German by the name of
Doberman was experimenting in the
laboratory with genetics and he took the
cells from a a whippet or a greyhound
mingle them with a Rottweiler and
created the nobleman and they named it
after him Satan has experimented in the
laboratory of Nature and was responsible
for some of these monsters what happened
to them the flood got them
now there is a monster in the ocean that
could live in water he's called a whale
he's called a gray whale the biggest
creature on Earth weighs tons and tons
but the dinosaurs were destroyed in the
flood because they were breathing
creatures and I thank God they were
because they were giants in the earth in
those days but since the flood we've all
been dwarfed and pigmentized by sin I'd
hate to run around and meet one of those
fellas today wouldn't you that's please
a young friend wants to know how old do
you have to be in order to be an adult
well let's give a legal answer in Most
states a woman is an adult at 18 A man
is an adult at 21. the truth is we ought
to be mature and grow up some folks
don't grow up when they're 50. next
place Pastor Brooks please tell me your
opinion what does the Bible say about
women preachers should they be allowed
to share their knowledge of the word of
God you don't need my opinion the Bible
does not preclude women speaking and
witnessing for Christ it does not say so
now there is no precedent for a woman
being included amongst the apostles and
so forth but we're living in the last
days and conditions and cultural
conditions have changed there is nothing
in the Bible that says it cannot be now
if you have a different idea you're
welcome to that next please
a young lady would like to know if it's
okay to kiss her boyfriend while dating
it's offending to God in any manner
you say in any manner the truth is it
could be there's a place for kissing I
recommend it highly to married people
the problem is they did too much before
they get married too little afterwards
and marriage becomes boring
keep up the niceties and the flirt with
one another
hug and kiss I've got an article in my
Bible a doctor said that there are women
who are nothing but walking Dr bills
when all they need is their husband's
arms around them do it within the
confines of marriage now these things
are Preparatory actions for the sex act
when you're young and you get into it
you are putting yourself In Harm's Way
I'm trying to be frank without being
indelicate
you're putting yourself In Harm's Way
you wait and the longer you wait the
more precious it will be when the time
comes
don't turn on the motor unless you plan
to take a trip
Pastor is it a sin to have a blood
transfusion
that's an interesting question and
frankly it's come in before is it a sin
to have a blood transfusion the answer
is no it is not a sin now I'm clear that
there are those who teach that it is the
Bible doesn't teach it at all what the
Bible sells us not to do in Leviticus 3
17 and in other places the Bible forbids
the eating of blood
the eating of blood the minute a person
eats it it begins to break down and
change its composition in the mouth as
it mixes with saliva it is ingested it
goes into the system it is further
broken down like food God forbids the
use of blood as food the blood that goes
in your vein a process developed by a
black doctor years ago that process has
saved millions of lives
and ladies and gentlemen it is not wrong
it's wrong to eat it next please Pastor
Brooks some people are urging our
federal government to pass a law forcing
teachers and students to have prayer
before classes would not such a law
violate the principles of separation of
church and state what does the Bible say
on that subject the Bible doesn't speak
about separation of church and state the
Bible does tell us about forced morality
it is always associated with Hedonism
God does not accept it he will not
accept worship that is forced he says if
you love me do what
now I believe in prayer I think you know
that don't you I believe in prayer but I
don't believe in Prayer by law
I don't believe in prayer forced and
enforced
and let me tell you there is no law that
says a child cannot pray in school
there's no such law
we are not talking about that we're
talking about a law that says you got to
set aside time for prayer as surely as
it happens there will be those who are
trying to manipulate and influence and
use this to guide people into certain
and respective and favorite religions
that is not in harmony with our
Constitution which says Congress shall
make no law favoring a religion now let
me tell you as a guy who went to school
a long time
I always prayed in school I don't need
any law you get some of those tests I
had to take you better learn how to pray
next please all right
our question for tonight a young person
I'm a youth and I would like to know is
it wrong to listen to music of the world
to watch a soap opera or any type of
movie now I'm going to answer this the
way I've answered it about three times
already I have to assume that somebody
wasn't here when I answered it if you
want me to tell you it's all right to
listen to rock and roll you got the
wrong man if you want me to tell you
it's a good habit to watch soaps on
television you've got the wrong man
television does not build on human
strength it builds on human weakness and
it tantalizes and it attracts and it
dips if people live the way they do on
those soaps it goes old grazing
but that is not the answer let me give
you the answer in English that's my
mother tongue let me see if I can speak
clearly
if you ever get converted
thoroughly
and you have a habit of praying
and studying God's word you will not
have to ask a question like that
because your tastes will change the
Bible says when you're converted All
Things become new when you are converted
you change
behold all things are new and if you can
enjoy this filth
MTV if you can enjoy that pray you're
not a Christian yet
when you are converted the Lord will
come into your heart and because it
offends him it will offend you someone
said that when we pray and I converted
doing God's will is but the carrying out
of our own impulses it's what we want to
do it's what we like to do now between
the time we are converted and we reach
that we struggle against sin so you have
to discipline yourself Jesus said If any
man would be my disciple let him deny
himself take up his cross and follow me
and that's how you develop character
that eventually will stand Sterling and
pure you cannot do everything you want
to do and be a Christian you have to say
no to yourself deny yourself until you
come to the place you have a victory and
you no longer even have to pray like
that